hello there it's update time once again
in fortnite and this time it looks like
a live event has been confirmed as well
as much more seven and io law just in
time for the next marvel comic book run
i'm adam maru here is my code if you'd
be so kind let's break down week seven
and eight in fortnite chapter three
season two
tilted towers is under attack wow right
now the battle for tilted is taking
place and like usual our job is to fight
back the imagined order with help from
the helmet-wearing seven guards look at
this place buildings reduce to rubble
and only a few remain standing rip pizza
pit as expected the no sweat insurance
building remains in perfect condition
just like the last time it should have
been blasted to pieces not even a
volcano can break this building apart
let's hope we can still say that in
another two weeks time here's something
that will bake your noodle those who
follow fortnite's twitter account may
remember this tweet on january 19th
fortnite said we've only had clonballs
for a day but if anything happened to
them we would eliminate all of tilted
towers and as we all know the colombos
were taken away and now four months
later we now know they were telling us
about the future we just didn't pay
attention so let's pay attention more
now a new loading screen has been
revealed picturing the final member of
the seven the order snooping on sloan
and the io let's take a moment to look
at what sloan is carrying here that's
the device we saw on day one which
removed building in fortnite which is
why by the way i support io but this
time the device has a new projection
upon it some sort of tower could this be
the doomsday machine we were warned of
all we know right now is something big
will happen at loot lake very soon
so it's star wars week and in game right
now take a look into the sky and you'll
see a star destroyer floating there
ominously overhead last update we found
out the imagined order had recruited
stormtroopers to help quash the uprising
on the island and now they can be found
in game at various locations you can
find imperial outposts manned by
stormtroopers who will remind you you
are rebel scum i agree blasters
lightsabers and limited edition missions
are now in game so jump right in and may
the fourth be with you hey does that
mean we're going to get an obi-wan skin
i think i could use an obi-wan skin
hello there jumping over to condo canyon
where we've been watching the return of
the rock legends they were spotted deep
in the sands and over the last seven
weeks they've wriggled free and reunited
this week i thought they had vanished
completely but luckily they're still
around just a bit further away go east
and you'll find the fantastic four at a
roadside dwayne is holding back his
family from impending doom because the
last time these guys were on the island
vehicles were not drivable luckily he's
aware of his surroundings and he's
making sure the road is clear before the
family cross where are they going what
is over there oh for science i checked
what would happen if they were struck by
a vehicle
yep just like you'd expect
sorry from one rock to another the
impossible rock had yet another
container added today a perfectly placed
blue one now sits on top of the yellow
one making this location extremely high
now a crazy high vantage point this
could be a coincidence but i don't think
it is look at this right now do you see
the ukraine flag
the yellow and the blue containers are
perfectly lined up as if they were on a
flagpole this has to be on purpose to
show unity with ukraine and it can be
seen for miles around nice touch
fortnite that's probably the end of this
pois growth but there are still a few
updates to go this season so we will
wait and see
pili has had a bit of a character arc
this season first being taught to drive
by you and then being promoted to a
field agent and placing top secret
information in the wrong place for io to
find he was then demoted again and sent
back to driving crashing an ice cream
van over a cliff edge
last week he had dusted himself off and
vowed to keep driving while standing
next to a bus or coach i bet you can
guess what happened and yep he crashed
again he took that bus and traveled all
the way around the island and then
crashed here just outside kony this ties
up another strange pileup of ruined
vehicles we've been watching for the
last few weeks they were here all along
to be crushed into by a human banana
very fortnite pili will hopefully be a
worthy driver by the end of the season
so he can take part in the end of season
event oh no what if pili meets the rock
family on his next driving adventure oh
i hope i'm wrong
here's a peculiar update the battle for
rocky reels is over and the seven won
once again yet this time the occupying
flag did not become the ego and ghost
flag instead it is the seven the crest
we expected to see all those weeks ago
has finally been added i checked on the
other locations too and this change is
everywhere the daily bugle coney and
condo the flag of the seven is now
flying front and center so does this
mean the ego flag was a mistake all
along or was epic teasing the return of
midas it's strange eh oh and doctor
strange is also at the daily bugle too
good timing mate back over to rocky
reels and the blimp overhead has crashed
just to the west of here north of
butterbahn and this is also very close
to the final io drill location which has
been taken by the seven the imagined
order sent five small drills through the
ground last season to set up forward
operating bases around the map over the
last seven weeks we've seen the seven
destroy them all pushing io back towards
covert cavern oh and here's a really
random but cool update there is now a
rift in llamas legit look at this a
llama will leave one behind for a few
seconds when escaping really useful for
mobility and a free rotation nice and
finally here's something i wanted to
tell you about for a few weeks now but i
needed extra proof and today i got it
just above condo is a field of cactuses
or cacti if you prefer many people
noticed a traffic con placed on one of
these so last update i counted how many
traffic cones were here it was five
and this week there are seven
so it appears at this location a new
cone is added to represent each week of
the season be sure to stop by and see
this modern art for yourself let's see
if there's anything else i missed this
week oh the yellow house above the
davara's corpse has been destroyed
during the battle for tilted towers this
spot has been through a lot first
surviving the tremors from the io drills
from last season to then being taken
over by the imagined order themselves as
a secret facility and now complete ruin
a great little touch in the back garden
is the football it's right in the middle
of the crater i hope it gets rebuilt one
day around the island all the npcs in
hiding are slowly reclaiming their homes
this week the butter barn was reclaimed
by this handsome chap last week lil whip
reclaimed the ice cream parlor after
being in hiding in a bookstore for six
weeks and the update before that saw
baobros get his restaurant back in condo
canyon little updates all add to the
storytelling oh and a quick fix the
vaults in game work again huzzah and one
last thing we can now fund the chopper
in game be sure to spend your gold
wisely so that's what's going on in week
7 and 8 in fortnite i'm currently
working on a story video which will
hopefully if i get my act together be
out later this week but don't i can't
promise that you know how rubbish i am
if you've used my code thank you very
much i haven't been on twitter recently
to reply but i will be very soon thank
you very much if you used code adamarro
it does make a huge difference to me
anyway i'm adam you're awesome i'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you